in the time it takes to watch this video
the federal government will borrow about
$6 million that's roughly how much
Travis Kelce spent on his new home in
Kansas City the government is borrowing
one Kelsey Mansion every minute 24 hours
a day don't believe me let's break it
down between September and January the
federal government added about a
trillion dollars to the national debt
that translates to9 billion per day or
6.2 million one Travis Kelce mansion and
every minute it also means that the
government borrows roughly
$100,000 every single second another 100
Grand another 100 Grand and now thanks
to Rising interest rates all that
borrowing is getting a lot more
expensive over the next decade we'll
spend $10 trillion just making interest
payments on the debt that's a decade's
worth of the GDP of Switzerland this is
not sustainable